Just before we get started with today's video,
I do wanna give a quick plug to my podcast, the casual criminalist.
We cover a lot of crimes, criminals, bad things on this channel,
and you guys love it. Those are often the most viewed videos.
So I thought I would do a podcast with a lot more dark stuff.
It runs through about an hour.
It comes out every week and it covers some of the darkest stuff that we could
find from the UK doctor is the worst serial killer in history to the American
socialite. He murdered her best friend with her car,
allegedly and got away with it and much more. It's also pretty laid back.
It's more free form.
It's a podcast it's even got the occasional laugh because isn't death hilarious.
Weekly shows wherever you get your podcasts.
The casual criminalist is the name and let's get into today's video.
It was a nightmare. Come to life. People were dying throughout the Chicago area,
poisoned by Thailand or capsules that had been laced with Sinai.
No one knew where the poison was coming from or who would strike next?
No one felt safe. The Chicago, Thailand or murders of 1982,
scared the hell out of America. It forced Johnson and Johnson.
One of the country's most trusted companies to Institute a massive expensive
recall while managing one of the most extensively studied public relations
crises in corporate history,
it caused massive changes to the way over the counter drugs were packaged and
sold changes that can still be seen today.
The federal governments was given new power to protect citizens from a new kind
of crime product tampering.
But despite one of the most extensive investigations in the country's history,
the killings remain unsolved almost 40 years later
In 1982, Tylenol was one of the country's most trusted brand names.
First brought to market 25 years before it now represented 35% of the over the
counter pain relief medications sold in America.
Like most medications sold at the time.
It was manufactured by putting a powdered form of the medication into a two part
gelatin capsule that made it easy to swallow.
The capsules were sealed by a machine,
but you could still pull them apart by hands.
If you were inclined to mix the powder and a glass of water,
Tylenol was manufactured by Johnson and Johnson while America's oldest and most
trusted pharmaceutical companies over 30 million bottles of Tylenol were on the
shelves of grocery stores and pharmacies throughout the nation.
On September the 29th, 1982, when elk Grove village a suburb of Chicago,
12 year old, Mary Cullman woke up with a sore throat in a runny nose.
Parents gave her a capsule of extra strength, Tylenol,
or from a newly purchased bottle in the hope that she would feel better enough
to attend school that day 7:00 AM though Mary was dead that same day in
Arlington Heights, another Chicagos,
a 27 year old post office worker named Adam Janice dropped dead to the horror of
his family,
his younger brother Stanley and Stan's wife there rushed to Adam's house to
console distraught family members, soon,
both Stan and there had painful headaches, a common symptom of grief.
They found a bottle of Tylenol in Adam's medicine cabinet and took some stand
died that day there two days later over the next few days,
three more died in the Chicago area. Mary McFarland, Val Hurst,
Paul Prince of Chicago and Mary re of Winfield as is common deaths in young
people under the age of 40 autopsies were performed to determine the cause of
death. And the results were shocking.
All seven victims had died of cyanide poisoning,
but where had the poison come from after investigation revealed that at least
some of the victims were known to have died taking Tylenol Casios police ran
tests and discovered that all five bottles taken from the homes of those who had
died. Capsules in them that had been opened.
And the acetaminophen inside was replaced with potassium cyanide powder.
The bottles came from different stores in the Chicago area and had been
manufactured in different batches and different factories.
So some kind of mishap at the manufacturing level was quickly ruled out that
left only one implication horrifying as it may have been that someone was by
iron bottles of Tylenol, opening them, tinging them with poison,
and then putting them back on store shelves for unsuspecting victims to take
home. Chicago had a serial killer on their hands.
One who wasn't even in the same room with his victims when he claimed their
lives.
Police knew as they had to act fast to prevent more deaths.
The media was alerted and they ran warnings on radio and TV stations throughout
the Chicago area. Within days, it was national news. Police went further.
They sent cars on patrols throughout the city,
using loud speakers to warn residents, not to consume any Tylenol products.
Police had found more tainted bottles of Tylenols,
still on store shelves in several places in Chicago.
And the drug was soon impossible to find in the city.
Not that anyone was buying it.
The news that a madman was poisoning strangers with tainted Tylenol pills,
shocked the nation and quickly started to panic.
As citizens far away from Chicago were convinced that the bottle in their
medicine cabinet had been poisoned sales of the drug nationwide plummeted
Johnson and Johnson had never faced to crisis like this before. In fact,
no company had ever dealt with something like this.
They quickly put together a crisis response team made up of top executives.
It was obvious that the company wasn't to blame for the death as they weren't
the ones responsible for putting the poison in the bottles.
But that didn't matter to the panicked populace Johnson and Johnson knew that
they would have to take drastic action in order to restore public confidence,
they immediately shut down production of the drug and pulled all advertising
related to it. Then they went further.
They issued a nationwide recall on Tylenol capsules at a cost of over a hundred
million. They offered to swap the capsules for Tylenol tablets. I stairs.
Those were solid and harder to TA with
A week after the deaths,
handwritten letter was sent to Johnson and Johnson corporate headquarters.
It read gentlemen, as you can see, it is easy to play cyanide,
both potassium and sodium into capsules, sitting on store shelves.
And since the cyanide is inside the gelatin,
it is easy to get bars to swallow the bitter pill.
Another beauty is that cide operates quickly.
It takes so very little and there will be no time to take counter measures.
If you don't mind the publicity of these little capsules,
then do nothing so far.
I've spent less than $50 and it takes me less than 10 minutes per bot.
If you want to stop the killing,
then why are $1 million to the bank account number 8,
4 4 9 5 9 7 at continental, Illinois bank, Chicago, Illinois,
don't attempt to involve the FBI or local Chicago authorities. With this letter.
A couple of phone calls by me will undo anything you can possibly do.
Johnson and Johnson were obviously worried that this was the poisoner and that
he, he was serious about continuing his reign of terror.
They were prepared to pay the ransom, but the FBI cautioned them against it.
Instead, the bureau sought to find the letter writer.
The bank account was traced to a company called Lakeside travel in Chicago that
had gone under and ceased operations. In April of 1982,
the envelope was traced to Lakeside as well.
The FBI investigated everyone connected with Lakeside.
They matched fingerprints on the envelope. A man named Robert Richardson,
whose wife that worked as bookie before Lakeside,
a warrant was issued for Richardson's arrest and a nationwide Manha began.
Despite the letter writer's threat,
no more poisonings were reported over the next couple of months,
the suspect was arrested at a public library in New York city on December the
13th, living under a different name.
It turns out that using assumed names was a common threads in the man's life.
Robert Richardson wasn't really his real name.
Either police identified him as James W. Lewis of Kansas city.
Jim Lewis was well known to law enforcement.
Previously diagnosed with schizophrenia.
Lewis had been fired from several jobs because of his September.
He'd been indicted for the murder of an acquaintance Raymond West in 1978,
but the case had been dropped because of procedural mistakes made by police
Lewis and his wife skipped town in December,
1981 to escape another arrest warrant in Kansas city for tax fraud had gone to
Chicago and assumed the alias.
Robert Richardson on the surface Lewis seemed a viable suspect in the title on
murders,
but further investigation revealed that Lewis and his wife had left Chicago for
New York almost a month before the murders.
And there was no evidence that he had returns.
What they did uncover was one hell of a grudge that Lewis held against the owner
of Lakeside travel.
Frederick Macka Lewis had been enraged when his wife's last paycheck from
Lakeside travel had bounced for insufficient funds.
And during a hearing in August where former employees of side tried without
success to recover owed wages from Mackay Lewis and Mackay got into a heated
arguments in which threats were exchanged on both sites.
Lewis became obsessed with getting revenge on Mackay.
He had the stationary from the company and he knew what the bank account number
for the company was because of bank statements shared during the wage claim.
Hearing police figured that Lewis planned to wait until an appropriate crisis
came along, such as an airline crash or a terrorist bombing.
And he would then write an extortion letter that would implicate Mackay while
they were investigating him. The, the more serious crime that he hadn't done,
the police would undoubtedly finds out all the criminal activity that he had
done and that'd arrest him for that. As it happens,
the title murders happened a month after he devised this scheme and left Chicago
Lewis was convicted of attempted extortion and sentenced to a 20 year jail town.
He was released on parole in 1995.
He was never charged with the Tylenol killings themselves,
but his part in the case was not yet over
While the police were investigating Jim Lewis, they also had another suspect.
Roger Arnold Arnold was an eccentric character who worked at the same
warehouses, the father of one of the victims, Mary Reiner,
one nights while drinking into local bar.
He reportedly talked loudly about his theories on the case mentioning that Sinai
was not hard to get on that. He had a stash of it at his place right now,
the owner of the bar,
Marty Sinclair overheard him and thought the whole thing was suspicious.
He informed police and the police brought him in for questioning the search of
his home,
revealed several illegal weapons and Aash of chemicals and chemistry equipment.
There was no trace of cite, however,
and no connection could be made between Arnold and the poisonings.
The police charged him with the weapons via Elations and an outstanding assault.
And let him go for months.
Arnold Stu angry with Marty Sinclair for ratting him out after drinking too
much. On the night of June the 17th to 1983,
he decided to confront the bar owner shortly after last call a man resembling
Sinclair emerged from the bar. It was 46 year old. John Deisha,
the patron of the bar that night, who didn't even know Arnold in the dark,
the intoxicated Arnold miss took for Sinclair,
walking up to him and shooting him to death.
The poor man had simply been in the wrong place at the wrong time.
As for Roger Arnold,
he would spend 15 years in prison after being convicted of secondary murder
before being paroled in 1999,
Arnold's name would never be brought up again in connection with the title on
murders.
In may of 1983, Congress passed a law making product tempering,
a federal crime product tempering had occurred before in the United States,
but never on such a large and random scale as the Tylenol or poisonings,
the highly publicized murders set off a wave of copycat crimes across the
country. Over the next few years, the most famous of these occurred in 1986,
when a Seattle woman stellar nickel was convicted of killing her husband and
next door neighbor with Exogen capsules that had been tainted with Sinai.
The motive in that case was financial nickel was trying to cash in on our
husband's life insurance policy.
Drug companies now knew that they needed to enact preventative measures to keep
crimes like this from happening again,
leading the way in the effort was Johnson and Johnson.
The company had suffered a huge hit in market share in the aftermath of the
murders.
And some pundit said they might have to retire the Thailand or brand altogether,
but Johnson and Johnson took a different view that they had to regain the
public's trust by proving beyond doubt that their products were safe in
November, 1982, the company had begun stocking shelves with Tylenol on again,
this time in a triple sealed temper resistant bottle,
they put coupons in newspapers across the country and flooded the airwaves with
advertising, emphasizing the safety of their products within a year.
Tylenol had recovered most of its market share in the pain reliever market and
remains today. One of the top selling brands of over the counter of pain,
relief, drugs, other companies,
soon followed suit and new TA proof packaging was introduced across the food and
drug industry. In 1989,
the FDA released new guidelines that codified the TA proof packaging into a
governmental expectation pill bottles sold today.
All have TA proof seals on them. Consumers know that if the seal is broken,
they shouldn't consume any of the pills inside just in case other medicine is
sold in individual blister packs that need to be popped out by hand.
The Tylenol poisonings also led to the demise of the capsule in drug
manufacturing.
Instead companies invented the caper to gelatin capsule that completely incase
the medicine as a single piece, instead of two pieces.
The caper along with tablets that have been made easier swallow,
thanks to redesigns and now industry standard for pills
Today almost 40 years after the crimes occurred,
no one has ever been charged with the Tylenol murders.
It is one of America's most famous unsolved murder cases,
but that hasn't stopped police from continuing to investigate on may the 20th,
1988,
a 30 year old woman named Lori Dan suffered a psychotic break and went on a
shooting spree throughout the Chicago suburbs,
wounding six people and killing an eight year old boy before committing suicide.
Before embarking on her rampage, Dan prepared,
baked goods and drinks that were laced with arsenic and mailed them to several
people and hand delivered several to others.
No one became ill because the poison was diluted and the food was bad tasting.
But the similarities to the Tylenol case were such that Dan was briefly
investigated as a suspect though. No connection was found in 2011.
Police sought DNA samples from the notorious Unibo.
It had Kazinski since the first four Unibo crimes occurred in Chicago.
A couple of years before the poisonings and Kazinski,
his parents owned a house in the Chicago suburbs that he occasionally visited.
But once again, this didn't go anywhere for many people.
The prime suspect continues to be Jim Lewis after his imprisonment for attempted
extortion Lewis,
couldn't seem to keep himself from talking about the Tylenol case.
He offered his help in solving the crime and dropped several diagrams and
theories about how someone might have carried poisonings most intriguing was the
so-called breadboard method.
Lewis said that someone could drill little holes into a wooden breadboard to put
the empty Tylenol capsules into,
in order to fill them with cide and put the capsules back together without
making a mess Lewis claims that you could do this in the backseat of a car and
thus replace the tainted bottles back on store shelves,
MI minutes after first purchasing,
making a getaway before anyone noticed for those that believe Lewis committed
the murders.
The theory goes that at some point in September of 1982 Lewis suffered a
schizophrenic episode,
he refused to acknowledge his psychiatric diagnosis and thus avoided being
treated for us in his break with reality,
his rage against Frederick Mackay was so overpowering that he became determined
not to wait around some sensational crime to be committed so he could write his
letter and send the police after Machai.
Instead Lewis would create one himself in early 2009,
following the publicity of the 25th anniversary of the poisonings police
formally reopens the investigation. They searched Lewis home in Cambridge,
Massachusetts, and seized several items reportedly for DNA testing.
The sticking point of course is that there is no way to prove that Jim Lewis was
in Chicago and is not New York at the time of the murders,
that there are possible ways he could have gotten back and forth without leaving
a trail.
The time period the crimes took place in works against investigators to in 1982
surveillance cameras were not very widespread.
Both purchases were made with cash.
A lot of forensic evidence that would've been collected at the crime occur today
was just not collected back. Then. Sinai was relatively easy to get ahold of,
and it was inexpensive. There's no smoking gun evidence to be found,
at least not so far. And the moral time that goes by less likely.
It is that anyone including Jim Lewis will ever be tried or convicted for
committing the Tylenol or murders.
And the $100,000 reward that Johnson and Johnson continues to offer for
information on the killer will go unclaimed.
The Tylenol case changed America in a way that few murder cases have seven
people died. An eighth person died as a result of the publicity of the case.
And the rest of the country was scared out of their minds.
It cost Johnson and Johnson over a hundred million in product equal costs and
forced the federal government to enact new laws,
to protect the public from the new found danger of product tampering.
It changed the way that medicine is marketed, packaged,
and consumed in America and hanging over it all is the mystery of it who
committed this heinous act? Why did they do it?
And why did they stop apparently vanishing into thin air?
The sad truth of it is that we may never know the answer and the Tylenol killer
will pass into legend as America's version of Jack the ripper.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below. Don't forget to subscribe.
Please do check on my new podcast, that casual criminalists.
There are some links below. Thank you for watching.